esta vez tengo varios ejercicios que
saque de la canacar de ming y vamos a
resolverlo rápidamente por ejemplo este
dice tenemos 5 mil 524 0 y bueno esta
vez estamos sumando 0 entonces estamos
sumando nada lo que quiere decir que mi
resultado va a ser 5 mil 524 no voy a
poner aquí 5 mil 524 muy bien hagamos
uno más ahora tengo este de aquí porque
el número tengo que multiplicar al 8 mil
895 para obtener uno bueno vamos a tener
que multiplicarlo por su recíproco o
podemos decir por su inverso
multiplicativo entonces eso hace lo
mismo que 11 entre 8 1895 y esa es mi
respuesta si multiplicas a 8 mil 895 por
1 entre 8 mil 895 vamos a obtener 1
así que vamos a hacer otro más dice qué
pasa si tomas a 1.555 y lo multiplicas
por uno bueno cualquier cosa por uno es
esa misma cosa entonces esto va a ser lo
mismo que en 1555 de lujo está fácil así
que vamos a hacer uno más nos preguntan
cuánto es mil 543 más 0 bueno recuerda
que estamos sumando 0 y sumar 0 sumar
nada entonces me va a quedar mil 543
bien otro más aquí tengo lo mismo 5 mil
800 40 bueno es 5 mil 804 muy bien vamos
a hacer uno más y dice que el número
debemos sumar al mil 893 para obtener 0
bueno esencialmente tenemos que quitar
1893 para obtener 0 estás de acuerdo
para que así no nos quede nada entonces
el número que debemos sumar para quitar
1893 es bueno menos 1893 porque si sumas
este más éste nos dará 0 bien vamos a
hacer otro más tengo este de aquí 7.360
por uno bueno eso está muy fácil lo que
se ha multiplicado por uno va a ser es
lo que sea que en este caso es 7.360 y
vamos a hacer un último
es este de aquí porque el número tengo
que multiplicar al 4.850 para obtener
uno bueno ya hicimos uno muy parecido lo
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicarlo
por 1 entre esta cantidad 4.850 y al
multiplicar estos 2 me va a dar 1 y
hemos acabado